you know during this time of crisis two
men have really stepped up and become
full-fledged
social media and TV stars and I'm
talking about
Governor Andrew Cuomo of New York and
his brother Chris from CNN millions tune
in each day to hear what they have to
say about the pandemic but you know
there's a lot you may not know about the
brothers even as chris continues his
public battle against the virus
today I am oddly Spacey it's hard to
have a fever for twenty hours a day it
just wears you down emotionally
I've lost 13 pounds in three days chris
has been brutally candid about his
coronavirus battle and that's one of the
reasons why ratings on his primetime
show are up 118 percent I know I have a
long way to go the source tells ET that
the 49 year old spends much of the day
resting his wife of almost 19 years
Christina is a wellness guru and
magazine editor she and their three
children
Bella's 17 Mario 14 and Karolina 10 have
all tested negative for the virus
chris is confined to their basement and
broadcast from there I'm a little
depressed
hard to believe that just one day before
chris started showing allergy like
symptoms
the super-fit anchor was shirring
workout tips at the beach tank one
bright spot in all of this thank you for
coming back to the show
mom told me I had to Chris's playful
banter with his brother New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo I called mom just
before I came on this show by the way
she said I was her favorite good news is
she said you were her second favorite
it's interesting to point out that Chris
was reportedly forbidden from
interviewing his brother until last
month when the coronavirus News made it
unavoidable but now their joke cracking
much-needed relief has garnered a bit of
a fandom inspiring tick tock videos
[Music]
and the hashtags Cuomo crush and Cuomo
sexual some are now even hoping Andrew
will run for president of course his
brother asked him point-blank have you
thought about it no are you open to
thinking about it no so what's behind
their unique bond well andrew is 12
years older than Chris and growing up
there were times when he was kind of a
father figure to the younger Cuomo their
late father is former New York Governor
Mario Cuomo he died just hours after
Andrew was sworn in for his second term
as governor in 2015 my father was always
working so it was always just me and
Chris and he's a sweet guy and now he's
parenting in the basement but his
funniest that he says to me even the
dogs won't come downstairs he says
Andrew is a divorced father of three
daughters including twins he split from
wife Kerry Kennedy daughter of the late
Robert Kennedy in 2005 he went on to
date TV chef and author Sandra Lee for
14 years the pair split last fall back
in 2015 she told us how he was by her
side as she underwent breast cancer
surgery
he said you're good I love you both
Andrew and Chris have law degrees they
also have three sisters Madeline is a
lawyer too Margaret is a noted
radiologist and Maria is a documentary
film producer who is married to fashion
designer Kenneth Cole meanwhile Chris
continues to social distance from all of
his family including his wife and kids
he talked to us about his family bond
back in 2016 I love my kids I mean
they're literally the motivation for
everything that I do right in my life
[Music]